gibt es ihn oder gibt es ihn nicht einen
riesigen planeten der sich um unsere
sonne dreht planet neun gemeinden abo
physikerinnen und physiker sind sich
einig dass er irgendwo da draußen in
unserem sonnensystem existieren muss
doch einen direkten nachweis bleiben sie
uns bislang schuldig nun haben spanische
wissenschafterinnen und wissenschaft
nach handfesten beweise für seine
existenz vorgelegt welche das sind und
wann wir den mit seriösen riesenplaneten
wohl endlich zu gewicht bekommen werden
jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
es ist schon fast ein bisschen peinlich
für die abfuhr physiker und
physikerinnen von heute achtung weiter
antike konnten sie tatsächlich nur zwei
weitere planeten in unserem sonnensystem
dingfest machen und das trotz der großen
technischen fortschritte in den letzten
100 jahren die entdeckung der
sogenannten planet 9
von dessen existenz die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
überzeugt wäre somit ein riesiger
durchbruch im bereich der astrophysik
der rose wettstreit um einen möglichen
neuen planeten unsere songs sind ist der
bereits vor jahrzehnten entbrannt
forscherteam weltweit jagen das phantom
und jeder werden verschiedene
anhaltspunkte für planet 9 haben
forscher sind bereits gesammelt mal mehr
mal weniger stichhaltig dadurch ist ein
relativ konkretes bild von diesem
mysteriösen riesenplaneten der wie es
wohl irgendwo in unserem sonnensystem
versteckt hält entstanden weiß nicht 9
handelt es sich nach meinung vieler
astrophysikerin und physiker entweder um
einen gesteinsplaneten mit dem
vierfachen er durchmesser und einer
masse die maximal zehn mal so groß ist
wie die der erde ein gigantischer
brocken also um es mal auf den punkt zu
bringen berechnungen legen nahe dass er
wohl 10 bis 20 tausend jahre braucht um
die sonne in einer langgezogenen
umlaufbahn zu umrunden
beim nachbarn zur sonne setzen vorstadt
dienst um etwa 20 mal größer ein als den
abstand der sonne zum planeten neptun
mathematische berechnungen eines
forscherteams aus madrid haben nun
weitere und bessere beweise für planet 9
gebracht dafür analysierten wie die
outfits der sogenannten ethnos darin
extrem franz neptunus objekte also kunst
neue himmelskörper also die ausgeprägte
exzentrischen also langgestreckte
umlaufbahn um die sonne kreisen minden
aber jenseits der bahn des äußersten
gasplaneten neptun
dabei machten sie eine überraschende
entdeckung alle der bislang 28 bekannten
ethnos werden genau wie 24 weitere
aktien im weitläufigen umlaufbahn
beeinflusst durch eine schwere bislang
noch nicht identifizierte masse
diese sei wohl verantwortlich für die
signifikante abweichung in den umlauf
waren der eu
mutmaßten spanische forscher teams noch
mal auf den punkt zu bringen ein planet
also der etwa 300 bis 400 astronomische
einheiten von den untersuchten e-plus
entfernten muss wechselwirkt mit ihnen
unsere ursache ihrer charakteristischen
umlaufbahn merkmale planet neuen lässt
grüßen dieses ergebnis stützt
tatsächlich auch die analyse der bislang
wichtigsten forschungsarbeit zu dem
gigantischen brocken noch im vergangenen
jahr hatten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus den usa
gemeinsamkeiten in den orbit sechs
verschiedener ethnos entdeckt
beispielsweise zeigten ihre messungen
dass die längsachse der elliptischen
umlaufbahn ungefähr in dieselbe
himmelsrichtung zeigten ein erstes ernst
zu nehmen sie für planet 9 und für eine
gravitationskraft wir auf andere
planeten ausübt und andere himmelskörper
doch es gibt auch astronom und
astronomen die trotz diverser hinweise
nicht von der existenz eines neunten
planeten ausgehen ihr argument die
bislang bekannten eigenschaften - seien
nicht repräsentativ und somit auch nicht
dieser ausgezogenen rückschlüsse auf
platz neun
denn selbst große teleskope seien
heutzutage noch nicht in der lage
transaktion diese objekte in ihrem
extremen umlaufbahn zu identifizieren
deswegen sei die existenz weiterer
ethnos denkbar deren eigenschaften in
keine rückschlüsse auf planet neuen
zuließen
doch der großteil der fortschritt lässt
der bahnpläne 9 nicht los denn es gibt
einfach so viele messungen berechnungen
die übereinstimmend auf seine existenz
hinweisen trotzdem ganz schwierig
kleinen nächster zeit zu entdecken zwei
probleme stehen dem weg zum einen ist
der bereich in dem sich dieser mit der
löwe planet versteckt hält viel zu groß
und zum anderen existiert in diesem
gebiet nur sehr wenig sonnenlicht diese
beiden faktoren machen die suche nach
planeten tatsächlich zur der suche nach
der berühmten nadel im heuhaufen so
läuft die fahndung nach planeten
weiterhin auf hochtouren und es bleibt
dabei seine entdeckung wäre eine
wahnsinnige sensation und könnte uns
ganz neue einblicke in die entstehung
und evolution unseres sonnensystems
liefern jeweiligen werdet ihr mit als
erste erfahren planet neuen entdeckt
wird wenn ihr kein video zum thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann durch mehr ihr ein abo
aufsaugen und vergesse ich den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
wird ein planet unsere erde zerstören
da geht es um den mysteriösen planeten
nibiru spannendes video natürlich also
nicht verpassen
draufklicken und viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt